Herbert Baumeister is the Hamilton
County businessman who committed suicide
in 1996 after detectives dug up the
remains of seven men buried on his
wooded estate if investigators are right
Baumeister was a serial killer many
visitors to the property have the sense
that the spirits of those killed here
still linger there's not time o clock
[Music]
what's up it's Tuesday again and that
means it's time for the latest episode
of 13 o'clock episode 82 specific 82
yeah I know man a piling up on us aren't
they I know it just seems like you know
we finished one and then I got a do
another yeah well since you started
doing the movie reviews dude yes like
I'm always working on one yeah the last
movie review people seem to like that
one though and had a lot of fans yeah
changeling yeah we did well like I said
it's that's kind of considered one of
the best haunted house movies ever I
think they're gonna like the next one
coming up - what I can tell you what I
didn't know so what's what's the subject
for today well today if we're doing kind
of like it's paranormal
and it's true crime all in one okay and
this was actually a listener request
although again I don't remember he
requested it because it was a really
long time ago but we're gonna do Fox
Hollow Farm run which actually I had
never heard of the serial killer that
this is about until I saw the thing
about the haunting at Fox Hollow Farm on
paranormal witness yeah right several
years ago and then I had to go back and
like research the crime because I'd
never heard of it yeah that was the
first time it came to my attention also
and I was like women I hold on what
serial killer is this and then you know
I didn't know I I didn't know about the
case yeah I didn't either
yeah so so that's kind of cool that we
found one like right at the right at the
junction between the two subjects we
usually cover so yeah we're gonna do Fox
Hollow Farm today and it's a hot
basically a haunting at a serial killers
house yeah so it's cool and like I got
really into this story and I've watched
like a [ __ ] ton different um
documentaries on it stuff so so we'll
get into that in a bit we already
mentioned the movie review we did which
was the changeling so go back and check
that out that was our most recent one
and probably I mean you know I can do
like all the shout outs and show like
that at the end cuz I feel like we can
just get into the topic well first we're
gonna do our news story okay now okay
here's a news story that I don't know
this really pissed me off a lot I guess
I figured since we did we're due
show about a serial killer that that was
targeting gay men I found this news
story about this [ __ ] judge well he's
a former judge now in Arkansas okay it's
already sounded good and he was just
sentenced to five years in prison
because what he was doing the [ __ ] is
72 years old okay alright what he was
doing was he was having these you know
people come men come in front of him and
it was like minor shames like traffic
violations you know little drug
possession kind of crap yeah and he was
saying oh well I'll dismiss your case if
you do quote-unquote community service
which usually entailed hey why don't you
come to my house bring some canned goods
like to give to charity that's part of
your community service now like take off
your pants and like bend over and let me
take pictures of you along with that
well they wanted to get their charges
dismissed it's like a lot of them were
poor they didn't really have you know
they didn't really want to pay the fine
so he was so this old creep era was like
having these poor people come in there
for like jaywalking or speeding or
whatever and having this like old let's
and [ __ ] like okay well let me take
these pictures vizsla you know yes
blackmail and now you foreigners know
why Americans don't trust Authority we
don't care what your job is there all we
don't care what your job is you just
can't be trusted yeah this [ __ ]
name is Joseph Beckman but yeah and yeah
he's 72 and he actually pleaded guilty
last year to charges of wire fraud and
witness tampering and they actually said
they were only gonna give him three
years that's what the prosecutor wanted
is that because oh he's old and [ __ ]
like that I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
old he is right he's a [ __ ] yeah yeah
but they said no five years oh it turned
out that he had done the same kind of
[ __ ] before like back in the 1990s in a
different County in Arkansas but he they
didn't file any charges cuz he quit so
then they let him go be a judge
somewhere else I don't know if
in check I didn't know being a judge was
an old boy network I well you thought
that everything and yeah you thought
that was like do you thought that was
about upholding the law and like being
hair and [ __ ] like that this is America
this is this is like out of this [ __ ]
horrible story this guy looks like such
he's he's so punchable yeah I love the
way it's like the priesthood yeah so
he's like he's not in good health I was
like yeah more baby actually his
attorney was trying to get him just
sentenced to home detention because yeah
his lawyer made this quote he called
what he was what the guy was doing he
quote unquote improperly mixed his
personal desires with his job I like
that I'm like okay yeah he's accepting
full responsibility will whoopty ship
for her okay so he's in jail
gotcha yeah I guess oh and it's like
funny because seven tears 72 years old
you ought to be ashamed of yourself
yeah grown-ass man I mean not that it
would have been any better if his young
good look at it he's still gonna crave
that you know it somehow makes it worse
see look these guys don't abuse any
power yeah yeah so it's weird cuz they
were investigating for something else
and then the somebody said hey did you
hear about all that weird [ __ ] he does
like with guys that come into court and
they were like no we didn't know about
that tell us about that then this whole
thing opened up so yeah Joseph Beckman
you suck you're in jail now good yeah
and he I'm sure he probably won't won't
live that long but yeah so I thought I
would do another story about a horrible
predator of men since that's with the
serial killer we're talking about today
so what's let's talk about the Fox
Hollow Farm haunting now I want to talk
about the haunting part first okay
because that's where I first heard about
this case all right that's how you want
to do it
well bless the part about the serial
killer is a lot more complicated and I
wanted to have
a little bit more time to get into that
it's a pretty cool case yeah it's a
beautiful property to tell you that it
really is and uh if they came to me and
said hey we would you know I'll give you
a good deal on the serial killers house
and they show it to me I go yeah yeah I
live in that well apparently the people
that were on it because I think the
paranormal witness episode it was from
season 2 yeah which I'm not sure what
year that was but the people who owned
Fox Hollow Farm now it's in Indiana yeah
and it's a huge huge property it's like
18 acres eighteen and a half acres some
show like that
now the couple that were on paranormal
witness their names are Rob and Vicki
graves and they moved to the property in
2006 now they they come on the land
they're like I guess they're pretty
wealthy I think she is a pathologist or
some kind of you know medical -
something like that yeah it's upper
income housing yeah it's yeah it's a
very very large house he's gotta be
somebody don't hassle yeah and
quote-on-quote be somebody yeah well not
not like us no so they moved to the
property in 2006 now they're going to
look at the property and they didn't now
they didn't know when they went to look
at the property that this was a serial
killers house because it had been quite
a while it had been like 10 years or
more than 10 years since that had
happened and you know they didn't really
immediately remember but when they were
looking around the property and Rob
graves said that he's like you know I
started to think that this property it
was so beautiful and it was like really
he called it a steal really reasonably
priced but you know if you've seen The
Amityville Horror or anything like that
he's like so then he was trying to
remember and he was like oh maybe this
is the property where that serial killer
lived like years and years ago so he
asked the realtor yeah and the realtor
was like yeah cuz yeah that's why you
get in such yeah that's why it's so
cheap
yeah that's why they're touring through
the house and the woman sees that they
had
they have a indoor pool yes I didn't
know you could have a pool inside your
house yeah she's like I liked her
enthusiasm about that cuz that would be
pretty rad I mean not wait and find out
what happened in there but you know what
I mean yeah killin field it was yeah so
yeah that was that was that and then so
Rob graves is like at first he's like so
I talked a bit thinking about it and I
was like now are we gonna be okay with
this like a serial killer lived here
there was bodies it's like you know
there's a lot of people and at first she
was kind of like I don't know that's
kind of yeah she's she's like I deal
with you know dead bodies she's like I
work in a hospital and all the time so
it wasn't so much that she's like but
when it's your own house you know that's
a little weirder so but finally they
were like you know it's so pretty and
it's the you know the place is just
gorgeous and like I said there's
pictures of it they cuz they did it on
Ghost Adventures of [ __ ] you and there's
pictures of it all day all over the
Internet of course it's like a Tudor of
mansion really your mini mansion and so
they eventually decide to buy it now
it's a mini mansion as as opposed to a
McMansion or a maxi mansion yes those
you guys who don't live in the United
States what a big mansion is it's
god-awful it's kind of like a house that
you pick out of a catalog and you can
mix and match whatever it is you think
looks really classy in this big old
mansion they call them a McMansion and
some of the people that buy these things
and build these things they have no
taste at all okay and these things some
of these things they just they just come
out horrid just google McMansion you'll
see well because you have like a little
menu of options that you can pick from
right yeah it's like out of a cos I got
it out of a catalogue yeah they're like
you can have this kind of feature this
kind of roof you can have these colors
you can have this you can yeah and you
can tell so many people have picking
these things out you know this might be
their first house they've just come into
money and they're not really sure what
what a nice like I was like one of that
one and what's that one I want that one
Allah Tala
oh yeah and put that on there and put it
put a moat around like a castle
like I want to lions on the outside this
house isn't that big and I wanted 40
gables yeah yeah I don't want and I want
like I want a lighthouse over here it's
they're just [ __ ] ridiculous man
yeah and then there's there's a couple
of them like just up the street from us
is where the football player the
basketball players live yeah and who
that team bought for bought bought a
piece of property and put like four of
them on there and the houses are huge
but it's not on a big piece of property
it's weird and you go you go they don't
look that bad though yeah those ones are
actually not not really no those ball
players didn't didn't order those that I
think the team ordered those for the
most of the big ones cuz we live in an
area where there's kind of a lot of
mansions or you know smaller versions of
it most of them are pretty ok look and
yeah you know they're not a lot of them
have like a Spanish influence which I
always thought was really just right
here on our corner the guy who owns hey
Ace Hardware he's the owner of Ace
Hardware his house is right there I
don't know if you know it but yeah yeah
it's a compound you came to see in there
but yeah McManus ok so they move into
this house you know this really
beautiful Tudor mansion now the first
thing that happened was kind of some
minor seemed like poltergeist activity
Vickie says that she was vacuuming some
gravel up from around the indoor pool
which is it's down in the basement kind
of I mean it looks like there's a
sliding glass door that goes to the
outside but I think it's on the lower
level of the house you talk about the
pool yeah the the pool house has windows
though you can see how well yeah that's
what I just said it has a sliding glass
door that goes out okay oh that goes
yeah cuz she said it was in the basement
but when when they showed it I was like
how is that the basement like a lower
low or it could be to that the house
might be on like several levels you know
like there might be the end of it might
be that it's a cool looking pool but
there isn't out outside entrance to the
yeah I love that something like that
yeah I wouldn't mind living there at all
yeah but yeah so she's vacuuming this
grabble up from around the pool and she
said that the plug the unit that it kept
unplugged right like seemingly by itself
now this first time it happened she was
just like oh I must have just pulled it
too hard they came out of the extension
cord or whatever but she goes and
plugged it back in and then she's doing
it again and then it does it again yeah
and then it does it again yeah and then
at some point she plugs it back in and
then she turns around to look at it and
it like shoots out of the extension cord
yeah like by itself okay and she's like
she's really yeah right that's what they
showed on the reenactment and she was
talking about startled she was about it
so that was the first thing that
happened a little bit after that as I
said Rob graves worked at a car
dealership and he had just hired another
guy named Joe LeBlanc who worked there
he was like a Salesman or something like
that and it kind of became buddies so
Joe is chronically late to work and he's
like it's just because he's like the
traffic was always so bad I lived almost
an hour away and all this other stuff so
I was thinking about getting someplace
closer so you know I could get to work
on time so Rob graves says to him well
you know we have like an in-law
apartment or house at Fox Hollow Farm
why don't you come and live there and
then you can just come to work and it's
not that far so Joe does that and they
told him that yeah this was a serial
killers house he said we didn't get
really into it because like I said it
had been 10 years and the property had
been totally renovated since then like
they had pulled out all the old
furniture and all the old I don't know
he said it he said pretty much
everything from that time was gone
so I guess it had been totally renovated
in the decades since the crimes had
occurred so he wasn't really bothered by
it so he moves in I don't blame him I
would have moved in too well yeah
looking at looking at the house it's a
gorgeous and like I said as far as I
know I don't know if Joe still lives in
the apartment but Rob and Vicki I think
still live there I wouldn't care if that
thing was haunted or not no me either
I'm like I'll put up with a lot of
haunting yeah how's that nice yeah you
know getting it that cheap I've already
seen stuff like that you know
poltergeist and uh you know which is
different than a haunting you know and
no our regular listeners know my whole
story and how it gone to that but I've
been into a bad house I've never been in
a haunted house but based on what
they're describing I could do with that
yeah I could do with that uh it would
scare me and then afterwards I was like
man did you see that
I never something else you know wow you
know ghosts Wow I mean [ __ ] of it I feel
like would probably be really upsetting
like percent of the stuff that happened
to Joe the other ones they didn't have
anything like how threatening happens I
would consider it kind of like a bonus
of the house in a certain way that it
had like a bonus feature that at a
random moment it just scared the [ __ ]
out of you yeah I mean you just have to
shake it back you know yeah all right
back to normal life yeah but I don't you
know this is the thing you know I'm very
skeptical about most ghost stories this
one I think is most likely out of them
all just because the background of the
house there's something kind of special
about that what happened to this house
what happened there I kind of give these
stories a little bit more weight than
normal yeah I mean there's not real
outrageous claims I mean they do see
apparitions but it's it's not a [ __ ] ton
of stuff no I mean it's you know it
wasn't a lot of stuff to happen there
that was on the show you know it
wouldn't surprise me like I'm like I'm
very skeptical about ghosts in general
but if any place is haunted it's
probably this place right I mean just
you know and just because you know we're
kind of skeptical about ghost stories
doesn't doesn't mean that we're saying
that that can't happen I'm not a
disbeliever in paranormal Newton either
Jenny I know that kind of stuff happens
and she's witnessed it too it's just
ghost phenomena would have to be very
rare so that means I think I think most
of those stories are fabrications but
there's a chance that I think that I
think probably some of the stories are
true yeah they could be yeah so then so
after the vacuum thing happened and then
Rob LeBlanc moves into the apartment on
the property now the first thing that
happens to him was kind of a weird dream
that he had he said as soon as he was
done moving in he was like really tired
and he just kind of collapsed on his bed
and fell asleep and he's like and then I
started having this nightmare where I
just felt like I had to run away like
that something was chasing me yeah and
apparently this nightmare was so vivid
that he actually it was almost like
sleepwalking like he actually jumped out
of his bed and started running across
his apartment and slammed into his
doorframe and he knocked a glass off a
table and like cut his hand all up and
all this other
stuff so he said the dream was very
upsetting he wasn't sure what was
chasing him but he's like he just felt
like he needed to get out of the
apartment because it was anything really
bad in there you see that's another
thing like if ghost exists what is it is
it a phenomena where your psychic
abilities latent psychic abilities are
seeing the past is it actually like what
it goes to be the soul of a person come
to warn you and it's actually there it
is a conscious being you know trying to
come at you through another dimension
nobody knows I think there are a lot of
different options it's probably more
than one kind of phenomenon yeah
well okay so the next thing that
happened is Rob's at home painting the
outside of the house Vicky comes home
from work and she's like looking at his
like oh that's a nice job he didn't
stuff like that she says then something
off in the woods like you know caught my
attention just like and I look over
there she's like and I see a guy in a
red t-shirt she's like any standing over
by the edge of the woods there's like in
his back was to me yeah and he started
slowly walking toward the woods and
she's like an as he's walking she's like
I realized that I can't see his legs
it's just enough room but it's just an
upper body yeah and she's like and then
I'm looking at him and then he just
disappeared she's like now I'm a
scientist right she's like and I am
super skeptical of this kind of stuff
and she's like what the hell was that
you know I mean now so she says to rob
she's like I saw a guy and so they go
and look and stuff and he's like well
maybe it was you know just a person he's
like maybe it's one of those serial
killer groupies that like hang out
around them you know yeah cuz because
they know that herb Baumeister lived
here and stuff like that and then they
didn't really think much more about it
but Rob did install security cameras
property because he thought that there
was someone wandering around and unless
I'm mistaken where she saw that
apparition is where the where they found
the bones of those bombs that was later
I was later on yeah so yeah that's
another creepy thing about this case
people those bones are still out there
they're still a lot of them are still
there they don't know how many people
this dude killed yeah well yeah after
and and they still find stuff there well
yeah it's as far as I know they're still
fine it's tough I mean it's a huge huge
property yeah that's and that property
is basically a killing field and a
cemetery yeah basically an ad hoc Samet
body dump
that's exactly what it is a body dump so
the next thing that happened again
happened to Joe in his apartment so he
says he's in there he's washing his
dishes and he hears a knock on the door
and he's kind of like okay I'm coming
and then he's like it just kept knocking
and then he opens it and no one's there
he's like he goes outside he looks
around there's nobody there he's like I
don't know who that was that could have
been knocking he's like and then he felt
like someone was watching him he's like
I just kept looking at all the windows
and stuff and he just had this creepy
feeling that someone was watching him
and then a couple nights later he said
he'd been living there about three weeks
at this point he had a dog named Fred he
lived alone with it was him and Fred up
in the apartment and he's like I used to
go out and you know walk the dog up and
down this big long driveway that they
had so he's walking Fred and he thinks
he hears something like in the woods and
he's liking the dog heard it too because
you're the ears pricked up and he's like
starting to growl and then Fred takes
off running like toward the woods and
he's like worried you know come back
here boy yeah then he sees a man in a
red shirt the dog is chasing the man in
the register and a man in a red t-shirt
if this is true and that means that a
dog can see a ghost yes well some people
say reports that okay well I mean Joe
saw him too yeah he said he didn't see
him at first he just saw the dog take
off running but then he saw the guy
walking and he said he walked into the
woods and he kind of vanished yeah so
Joe is like freaking out because he
thought it was a person like he didn't
know if it was some guy that was like
lurking around the property cuz he
evidently at this stage he didn't know
that Vicky had also seen a guy in a red
t-shirt wander around so this is the
first time that he's seen him
yeah I just find it interesting that a
dog or an animal can see a ghost yeah
evidently based on this story that means
it's not happening within the human mind
that's what I'm saying that's that's
kind of cool
yeah so he so he runs into the woods so
he said he was really scared cuz he
didn't know if it was a real person or
not but he's like you know I had to run
there get my dog back so he runs in the
woods and apparently he sees the guy
like and he looks him right in the face
right and that like freaking the hell
out now
he told Vicky about this the next day he
said yet and he showed er he's like I
saw him and he's like walking with
purpose it's like toward the woods and
we had a red t-shirt and Vicky was like
holy [ __ ] I saw that too right like
right around the same area yeah you know
then they kind of knows like okay what
the hell is going on is this a person
who's hanging around our property or
what and then I'm guessing this was
either the next night or a couple nights
later or something like that
Joe is sleeping it's like the middle of
the night then someone starts banging on
his door yeah this is a pretty creepy
episode right here yeah the story in the
way this guy tells this story he's
credible yeah sounds like it really
happened to him you know I mean the way
it the way you can so so they so he's
welcome to NOLA night this buddy's
insistent banging on his door and he
keeps yelling out like who is that who
is that but no one would answer he's
like in the banging just gets more
violent and violent and he's like and
he's touching the door and he's like you
can feel the door like vibrating yeah
that from the rocks are so hard yeah and
then finally he whips the door open and
there's no one there yeah but here's the
creepiest detail the knocker on the door
his stant is sitting horizontal like
someone was holding it at a 90 degree at
a 90-degree angle and then it drops back
down and knocks one more time now I
don't know if it's the same knocker
because I saw on Ghost Adventures they
do actually have a knocker it's it's
actually kind of a creepy looking
knocker it's like it's a long silver
horse head okay like with a you know
with a knocker thing over it they didn't
show it like that on paranormal witness
but that's what it really looks like
yeah he's like that was really freaky
like that really scared her death
because he opened he's like there was
nobody there would anybody there and
before I forget I think one of the best
programs on this case is actually the
paranormal witness one and you can see
that for free on dailymotion yeah under
Fox Hollow Farm yeah now there's a lot
of good stuff about this case on YouTube
where some of these paranormal
investigators some of them are small
channels to have gone to this place and
done in investigations now we didn't
really have time to watch them all
there's a lot of them and some of those
things are like 3-4 hours long
yeah but you know if you want to know
more about this case after we get dumped
the show you can go check it out yes I'm
been to this place we watched the
paranormal witness about it I watched
the Ghost Adventures episode about it
which you know wasn't really all that
great and there's one there's a
actually quite a long documentary called
the haunting of Fox Hollow farms that's
available for free on YouTube I watch
part of that that's mostly about one
investigation although it's a lot of the
paranormal investigators talking to the
houses owners and talking about the
history of it and stuff like that I
didn't really watch too much of the
investigation because yeah because it
seemed like well it didn't seem like a
not a lot happened right just like The
Ghost Adventures show I think on The
Ghost Adventures show pretty much the
only thing that happened was they were
in Joe's apartment and they were like oh
look that looks like a wisp of something
which I didn't even see it didn't look
like anything and then they were like
one of the guys was in there and there
was like a knock like the knocker
sounded like the knocker - twice but
they didn't have the camera on it so
well that could have been anything
yeah ghost is not gonna be reliable it's
not gonna perform on cam yeah I think
that's gonna be some kind of spontaneous
phenomena that it only happens maybe
once every couple months it's gonna be
something like that yeah so after this
whole thing and Joe opened the door and
there was nobody there so then he closes
it up again and locks it and then the
dog starts to growl and then he said he
saw the doorknob turning and he's like I
could see it turning I could hear it
turning man I would freak well he seemed
like he was right I'm waiting the dude I
mean like he was [ __ ] terrified right
the dogs rolling the door he grabbed me
I'd be grabbing all the guns something
was coming in on me like that
and then all of a sudden he says the
door flew open yeah he's like and it hit
the wall like on the inside and he's
like woodchips flew in yeah and he's
like wigging out like he's running
outside going who is that what the hell
is going on and then he turns around and
sees a guy in his apartment he's like
the guy now I don't think he said this
on paranormal witness but I think I read
something else that he talked about
where he talked about this experience
experience but he said this guy was wet
yeah and he said and he looked terrified
he's portrayed as wet and terrified and
yeah yeah he didn't I'm just saying he
didn't say that they did reenact it like
he'd gotten out of the pool yeah yeah
they said there's just look of terror on
his face and he was like screaming and
you
he was like running through the
apartment yeah which kind of like makes
it leads you to believe that at least
some of these ghosts are the ghosts of
terrified victims trying to escape
there's at least one of them all right
so that's yeah and that's actually what
ends up what they think and ever
happening because since then he ended up
telling Robin Vicki about that and you
know Vicki had seen the red shirted man
too so they said maybe we should
investigate this case all because they
said we'd heard about it but you know it
happened like 10 years ago we just
remembered vaguely hearing about on the
news or whatever so they actually called
the local news station and the news
station gave them some footage like from
the time and they had a bunch of
pictures of the victims that had been
identified there's not very many and I'm
gonna get to that in a bit but one of
the victims that came up Joe said that's
him that's the guy that I saw in my
apartment identified him so he
identified him from that and apparently
he had never seen that guy before he
just recognized someone he saw the
picture he's like that's the guy that I
saw in my apartment that's pretty creepy
yeah that is pretty creepy but then the
next thing that happened this this kind
of thing is where maybe you wouldn't
want to live there because so Joe
invites his friend Jeremy over to the
house and Joe and Jeremy are swimming in
the pool along with Rob and Vicki's two
sons they'd like two teenaged son so
they're all swimming at the pool having
a good time I think they were he said
they were like picking dead beetles off
the bottom of the pool or something like
that just when you know farting around
and he says suddenly he swam to the edge
of the pool to put like a beetle on the
side and he felt something touch his
back or touched the back of his neck
and he turns around like thinking it was
one of the other guys he's like no they
were all on the other end of the pool so
it wasn't then he's like so then he
starts swimming back to them and he's
like I distinctly felt two hands
grasping me around the neck and like
trying to choke him yeah and his friend
Jeremy was on the show too and Jeremy
was saying you know we didn't really
know it was going on because all of a
sudden he was in the pool and he just
had his hands up to his neck like he
said and he looked terrified
yeah and he like so he just like jumps
out of the pool and tells all them just
get out get out of the pool you know
there's this something bad in there
think we gotta tell him what his what
this guy's method motive operation was
is how he killed well that's what well
I'll guess then I guess part because
that you know then that'll tie back in
oh they'll tie into that right yeah and
then the next thing that happened a lot
of this [ __ ] happened to Joe actually
now that I'm thinking about I mean Rob
and Vicky did report like I said I've
seen some other ghost hunter type shows
that have them on it and they said they
still hear noises and see things every
now and then too but a lot of the stuff
that was on paranormal witness was
actually reported by Joe in his
apartment and then the next thing that
happened to him he's like I was sitting
in the apartment one night like on my
computer or whatever and he's like and I
hear this weird metallic scraping sound
like coming from the kitchen he's like
so I go over there and I see that all
the knives have come out of the butcher
block and they're all laying in the sink
Wow then he looks up at the wall and
there's like knife marks all over the
wall then I evidently were not there
before I'm not sure this is that's
pretty uh
that's pretty impressive because that's
some similar [ __ ] to what happened in
your case yeah that's why I'm bringing
that up it's in ghost cases or reports
of ghosts it's rare that objects move
you know moving objects usually takes
place in poltergeist phenomena which is
are spk really it's more like instead of
spirits of the Dead poltergeists really
in the classic sense of the word
is a situation more kind of like what
you saw the movie Carrie it seems to be
unconscious psychokinesis of a
pissed-off person so to find a ghost
that can actually has the strength or
the power to move objects especially you
know heavy objects it's rare so it's
significant I would say in the case yeah
so he sees these you know these knife
marks all over the wall and then he says
you know he's like maybe somebody got
murdered in this apartment yeah because
they're not really sure like I said they
don't know how many people this serial
killer killed they don't know where he
did it they think it moves mostly around
the pool area but they're not entirely
certain of that so it's entirely
possible that someone might have been
murdered in this apartment who knows
right so he decides he's like you know
I've seen all the ghost hunter shows and
they do EVPs and [ __ ] like that so he's
like well I'm gonna try that out so he
said so he specifically said I unplugged
everything he's like I unplugged the
fridge I turned off the fans
everything that could make noise so he's
like and then I turn on my voice
recorder on my phone and he's like I
kind of felt stupid doing it because I'm
just like talking in the dark but he's
like asking is there anyone here with us
all this other kind of stuff and as he's
talking then the the dog starts growling
as though someone's in there and he said
he kind of felt like someone was in
there now when he listened to the
recording back and they did actually
play the actual recording on paranormal
witness cuz they used they will do that
a haunting won't they usually that's all
reenactment but paranormal witness if
you have any real audio or photos they
generally will show that so they did
play the audio it definitely sounds like
a man's voice he said he thought it said
because he was saying who's with us or
who's in here and he said it sounded
like it said the married one right which
it kind of sounds like that it's for
sure sounds like a voice like it doesn't
just sound like most EVPs to me just
sound like this actually did sound like
someone talking I'm not sure if that's
what it said it did kind of sound like
that now he thought that was kind of
weird because he's like you know all of
her Baumeister's victims as far as they
know were single Gaiman mmm so he's like
the only one that was married was herb
right their murderer right so he's like
hopefully he's like I don't know he's
like so hopefully it's not [ __ ] the
ghost of herb hanging around in the
apartment because that would be pretty
freaky however you know if this
experience that he had in the pool with
feeling hands around his neck and stuff
like that is true then that was probably
herb - so her you know it wouldn't be so
bad if it was just like the ghost of the
victims you know I mean that would be
creepy enough but that but at least
they're not you know actively trying to
hurt you so yeah so it would seem and he
does actually seem to think that that
the serial killers ghost is hanging
around over every - Oh her yeah you know
what's so funny is that you hear the
name her but now you see the picture and
he just does he looks like a creepy old
pervy closeted gay dude that kills
people it says hey I think he just looks
like he is very weird looking yeah and
evidently the guys that knew him said he
was scabby
you know that he yeah
kind of dirty well his house was out he
wasn't particularly dirty good so that
was pretty much what happened on the
paranormal witness episode as I said I'm
pretty sure the graves still live there
Robin Vicki I think when they did Ghost
Adventures they were still there you
know every other paranormal show I saw
they were still there you know they do
let paranormal teams in periodically to
investigate if they want to so evidently
the haunting is not so bad that you know
they that it makes it unlivable yeah I
live I mean you know yeah it would be
freaky if somebody like you thought so
much strangling your ass in the pool but
you know but if it only happened like
once in a while maybe you know like
maybe once a year though it would be it
would give you hit someone talk about
yeah that's true yeah I guess what's
weird it's just what's out in those
woods you know I never know what never
know when you're gonna find a bone well
and they did oh I forgot to mention that
they said Robin Vicki and Joe where they
saw the like right around the area where
they saw the red shirted guy they found
a human femur
yeah and there's a picture if they
called the cops and everything because
they're still like I said they're still
bones all over the problem yes some
people might be upset about that but you
know you know how to spending a lot of
time in the country and no no in the
wild in nature you know you go to any
one of these little forests and little
sets of woods that we have have around
here those are dump sites those are body
dump sites for all kinds of creatures
yeah this filled with dead squirrels and
rabbits and just creatures died you know
there's it's full bones out there
something but in this place some of them
happened to be humans you know but yes
so and actually on some of the other
paranormal shows that I saw that we're
more recent than this
Robin Vicki did say yeah we still do
periodically yeah and human bones on the
property and occasionally a little bit
on the neighbor's property if you take a
nice walk out to those beautiful woods
you know there's bones of dead animals
everywhere well yeah
everything dies everywhere every house
is built on a bunch of places built on a
bunch of bones too animal bones well
yeah some of them human bones you never
can tell what happened
yeah that's one of the things there
flies on the windscreen is everywhere
yeah it's part of nature so yeah so that
was the paranormal witness episode like
I said there's it's available on
dailymotion a couple people and put it
up it's actually one of the better
episodes I thought yeah this is one of
the you know I said I think this is one
of the more credible haunted house
stories yeah like I said they didn't I
mean they did see a lot of apparitions
but they didn't have any super crazy
yeah and they seemed pretty level-headed
yeah yeah something actually did happen
at this location and the claims are not
real about radar yes you know it's just
the basic reports of you know
apparitions yeah apparitions and hearing
things and you know this is a likely
spot you know that's if there are
haunted houses this would be one of them
well yeah it would be a very good
candidate candidate yeah so we're more
about it the halfway mark now so when we
come back I actually want to talk about
the serial killer in question and the
[ __ ] that happened on this farm yeah a
decade before Robin Vicki moved in there
that's gonna be pretty interesting and
it shows yes this is a pretty creepy
case yeah and like I said this is the
first time I had ever heard of him was
on this paranormal with this episode so
I decided to go back and look him up so
we're gonna take a break and we'll be
back in just a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so let's talk about Herbert
Baumeister know her now we say serial
killer technically I guess he's only an
alleged serial killer because he died
before he could be arrested or charged
with any of the crimes that he is
suspected of committing but let's be
honest here you're pretty sure he did
this [ __ ] he didn't want to face the
music
that's kind of what I'm thinking right
now this guy is he's kind of seems like
kind of a weird dude now from all
accounts his family were like his
parents were kind of well-off his dad
was a doctor and stuff like that he had
a pretty normal childhood his wife
called it a beaver cleaver upbringing it
was very just a very normal childhood
now evidently when he got into his
teenage years he started acting
different they said he became very
volatile very belligerent he was clearly
very intelligent but he started to get
to a point where he really didn't have
an idea of what was appropriate behavior
yeah anymore
and he got into a lot of trouble now
evidently he was diagnosed with most
sources say schizophrenia a couple
sources I read said something different
but it was similar to that so it he had
some kind of mental illness which seems
to have developed sometime in his
teenage years it's so funny I'm sitting
over here just going yeah come on
hmm I'm starting to feel like I'm Flavor
Flav I'm like your hype man big clock
around my neck yeah come on he'll always
be my flavors I'm totally by about the
same size yeah I'm gonna bite her big
yeah come on it'll be like half as big
as you yeah yeah this did it again yeah
well it's funny because I feel like I do
that cuz usually when you're talking
well because when you're talking if you
kind of go off on a tangent or something
like that then I want I don't want it to
make it seem like I'm not listening yeah
I'm helping you yes
and then I say yeah which you know I
know it's annoying like I tried to take
it out sometimes when I play yeah just
call me Flay okay all right Thank You
Schofield yeah so apparently he had some
kind of mental illness like he started
carrying dead animals are in his pockets
like he would pee on his teacher's desk
[ __ ] like that
oh yeah the boy does I guess I guess
yeah now he went to Indiana University
initially he was going to study Anatomy
I don't know if he wanted herbes parents
wanted it he was going to thinking about
being a doctor but he didn't last very
long he dropped out and then his dad got
him a series of you know kind of lower
end jobs I think his first job was um at
the Indianapolis Star I think was the
newspaper he was like a copy boy which
you know that's just a guy that's like a
desk from college really no he dropped
out silver spoon yeah okay I mean he was
evidently very smart yeah like a weirdo
you know now it is here in the United
States especially during that era though
if you didn't have that piece of paper
you didn't have that was kind of like
your permission to make money and to
have a job yeah so he started out as a
copy boy
they said the weird thing about him in
that position because this was kind of
his you know this first job that he
hadn't like I said his dad kind of
pulled some strings and got it for him
yeah they said that he would show up
every day like even though it was kind
of like a lower-level job and stuff he
would show up every day like
immaculately dressed and he was very
eager to please to the point where
people found it off-putting act yet like
sounds like he's slightly autistic maybe
well but like I said yes burgers you
know yeah I don't know it's it seems
like it might have been something like
that but he definitely seemed to have a
problem acting right run and he seemed
to like people seem to respond to that
in him like they thought that he was
playing a role or they just found him
very weird they're like hard to relate
to so like I said I think a lot of
people at the newspaper where he worked
thought he was very overeager he was
always kind of fishing for compliments
like trying to get recognition and stuff
like that and I think people didn't
really like that and they thought he was
a weirdo so like then he went on to
another job which i think was at the
Bureau of Motor Vehicles and they said
now at that job people there
said that he was like the opposite like
he was like super bossy and like acted
like a dick all the time like like this
is oh this must be what I'm supposed to
do the people didn't like him then
either now even back then and this was
the early 70s apparently some of his
co-workers thought he was a nut and also
that he was a closet case okay so people
were recognizing that yeah clarify maybe
you know some people in England in UK
the closet case is actually kind of like
a gay guy who's trying to choose that
denying yeah keeping it under wraps yeah
he's trying to deny it which probably I
mean a lot of people did I guess and he
was very conservative his family were
very very conservative he actually met
his wife Giuliana when they were both in
the Young Republicans at Indiana
University cuz like I said he went for
one semester and then he dropped out and
I think he went back for a little while
later but I don't think he ever finished
yeah what's funny is you know that
closeted guys Toby you know Toby's a
friend of ours he he's one of the
coolest leather daddies you'd ever meet
once the one time Toby said man never
messes those closet closet it he says
there they're weird do what he says this
guy was definitely weird you know I
guess you know you have a guy who you
know he doesn't feel good about being
gay but he's gay you know trying to keep
it under wraps it makes a lot of
internal conflicts well yeah mental
problems well yeah I think that's what
messes a lot of people up and like I
said I think that's why it's so much
better now because it's like you can be
gay and it's fine and no one cares you
know maybe back in the 70s it was still
like a huge stigma attached to it and
especially for someone like him like I
said he was very he seemed not nerdy
it's it's hard to describe him like they
show I've seen some documentaries
there's been a ton of documentaries done
about this guy they had one with that
Bill Curtis fella a secret life of a
serial killer crime stories did a show
about him behind Mansion walls did a
segment on him you know it's like rich
people that kill people but he he
definitely seemed warped you know very
warped it's weird because when you see
these videos like they showed like a
Christmas video of him and his family
and stuff like that he just comes across
like super say it's not it's not healthy
my advice to you if you're out there if
you're gay
Begay well yeah like a keep our gay man
well they said nowadays you need nobody
nobody gives a [ __ ] and I think that's
so much better like I think people are
much more mentally healthy because the
vacuum just nobody gives a [ __ ] because
you can just be how you want it no one's
gonna get up your ass about it
yeah or anything like that so yeah so he
ends up meeting this woman Juliana like
I said they were both you know they they
went to college like during the hippie
era and they were kind of like well we
were in the Young Republicans Club and
we were you know they seemed kind of
square and and they were all like oh
they wanted a family and all this other
kind of [ __ ] so they evidently kind of
hit it off now about six months after
they got married herbs dad had him
committed to a mental hospital yeah so
apparently he was having some problems
right um he was in there for two months
and then he got out now eventually herb
and his wife had three kids and by all
accounts he was a really good dad like
the kids loved him he spent a lot of
time with them and now I don't know if
this is true this is on one of the
documentaries I saw about him I I can't
remember who it was but I think it was
like a friend of the wife or something
and she said that the wife had told her
that they that her and herb had only had
sex six times like did the whole time
that I was like well three of those most
effect
I mean she had a kid so you know I'm
like so the other three times were just
with that's true he just married her for
looks that's what he's called his
mustache or his beard
I don't know giant [ __ ] cases go watch
[ __ ] case cinema on YouTube is the most
hilarious dude first British dude he's
from Yorkshire he's [ __ ] awesome you
can't eat reviews just like Shay great
yeah and you never can really tell what
he's gonna get what he's gonna give us a
range I really do love that guy yeah
it's funny it's been doing it for 10
years and yeah Johnny [ __ ] case if you
out there bro we will sit there and like
just Blake oh my god he's so funny
yeah showcase em oh [ __ ] case cinema
that's what's called yeah okay so like I
said herb and Julie that you know they
have three kids now at some point he
gets he gets a job at a thrift store and
even though he at first kind of thinks
the job is quote unquote beneath him cuz
he was one of those he actually starts
to think hey you know thrift store maybe
this might be a good business so he
spent three years working there learning
the business and stuff like that and
then he borrowed some money from his mom
and opened up his own thrift store like
a big one over him and Giuliana opened
up their own thrift store and it's
called safe a lot nothing to do with the
grocery store chain called save a lot I
don't know you know I don't know if you
guys have those where you are but we
have them here in Florida and they're
it's I don't it might not be a national
chain I don't know this wasn't that this
was save SAV - a lot not livening you
know I mean this kind of trips me out
imagine you're in these stores you know
I mean you're like in a Dollar General
Store you're in this little little bit
and that stores owned by a serial killer
man that you never well he's never no no
yeah you would never know well I'm sure
a lot of people have had that experience
cuz I do a lot of people shopped at that
store yeah they didn't know what was
they just thought oh it's that it's that
nice you know that story so evidently
this store did pretty well at this point
I think it was 1992 they were making a
lot of money and their kids were in
private school and stuff and they
decided we want a big property that's
like kind of out of the way like away
from the city and stuff so they purchase
Fox Hollow Farm now this is an idyllic
existence you know they have the kids or
run around in the yard and they said
it's just it's wonderful this whole you
know she's waxing philosophical about
how awesome it is and on the one
documentary I saw now an interesting
thing that and I forgot to mention this
before and this is something that's not
really mentioned on a lot of
documentaries about him I only saw this
on some really kind of intricate
write-up about his life evidently he'd
been arrested before once for drunk
driving in a hit-and-run mmm he actually
I think he got off on that and he also
was charged with stealing a friend's
car and conspiracy to commit theft but
he beat those charges alright so he had
a little bit of a record yeah and that
doesn't seem to be mentioned on a lot of
the stuff it's just funny how a guy like
this could get it get a big house like
that I need a big house like that
oh yeah yeah yeah he just got weaseled
his way into it well no I mean he did
open the business I think he did that
was his dad's money didn't
his mom's money his mom's money he
borrowed some money for his mom nowadays
you could you couldn't own a store make
that amount of money to buy a house like
that yeah because I believe in 1992 they
paid a million dollars for that yeah it
is it is out the middle of nowhere but
it was in a wealthy area oh yeah it was
like a Westfield Indiana it's actually
um I think it's about 20 miles north of
Indianapolis yeah and it's like and it's
a really nice area it's horse farms
mansions all that kind of [ __ ] so in
1994 one of the Baumeister's children is
playing in the woods like they do I
think it was the son I think his name
was Eric he was 13 and he finds lo and
behold a human skull yeah like you do
sometimes you're out there you just find
a head right on your own property so
yeah so he goes to his mom and he's like
you know hey I found a skull out in the
yard
do you have it with him did already
leave it on I think he left it out there
and had her come and look at it like I
think he picked it up and was like hey
so yeah they went out there and she's
like huh that's odd right yeah did she
report it to the police
yeah no she asks herb when he gets home
from work why is there a skull in our
backyard yeah like he would know ya know
he gives her this [ __ ] answer yeah
he's like oh well his dad was a doctor
an anesthesiologist I think oh and that
was my dad's one of his lab skeletons
and it was in the garage and you know
maybe you know an animal like dragged it
out of the garage like that and she
bought it yeah she was like oh yeah I
suppose so
right no offense but I watched a
documented the one with Bill Curtis I
think had kind of extent extensive
interview with Giuliana and I think this
is this was many years ago but I don't
think she knew that her husband was a
serial killer she's pretty gullible
though but she doesn't seem like the
brightest bulb right um you know I'm
just saying yeah like the weird thing is
that
she said when they found the skull she's
like she first said head and then she
said skull or whatever round thing and I
was like what could be that it was the
skull but the face wasn't attached to
this go so I might have just it looked
like a whole skull no they showed like a
reenactment but sure but then later on
like on the same show I think they said
that it was a whole skeleton okay but
most of the stuff said it was just a
skull so she believed what he said
because that's what she wanted to
believe she didn't want to lose that
house yeah I suppose so and you know
like I said they had quote unquote
perfect life even though I mean from the
outside it seemed perfect but when I
mean later on when everything came out
it actually ended up that they had been
fighting and had separated many times
you know leading up to the final and
actually I believe even before they
moved to Fox Hollow Farm he had actually
filed for divorce well I mean they don't
have sex
yeah but evidently they they reconciled
later and stuff like that so so it
wasn't as idyllic a situation as it
initially appears yeah so yeah skull and
she doesn't say anything now meanwhile
in Indianapolis in the gay community
several men have gone missing right
particularly now Indianapolis I'm not
sure the the Bill Curtis documentary
said that and I guess this was at the
time this was happening which was in the
early 90s they're like you know Indiana
in general and Indianapolis even though
it's a big city are very very
conservative it's very red state they're
like so even back in the 90s crimes that
had gay men as victims were not really
particularly cared about and the sad
thing was that when these men started to
go missing the media didn't really
report it they said the gay papers
picked it up and started writing stories
about it and they would actually
circulate flyers like in the nightclubs
to try and figure out what was going on
because it really didn't seem like the
police gave much of a [ __ ] so there had
been a few disappearances and really it
didn't come to the police's attention
until one of the vanish men's mother I
think that I think
his name was Alan Broussard and she went
to the police and said that her son was
missing she like you know he went out to
the club to meet his boyfriend and he
never came back and that's not like him
now she reported him missing the next
day but apparently in Indiana and I
don't know if it's still like this now
they won't do a full investigation on a
missing person of an adult for 30 days
it's ridiculous I'm like really and I
mean they had this woman on there and
she was saying well you know this is the
United States and if you're an adult and
you want to disappear then you have
every right to do that
she's like unless you know unless
there's obvious signs of signs that
something bad happened like there's
blood all over your apartment they're
like so they didn't investigate it so
the mom was like okay well I don't like
this so she went to a private
investigator right Virgil vandagriff now
he used to be a cop so now he's a
private investigator
now weirdly about a week later he gets
another call from another mother and
says my son is also missing and he also
hung out at the same bars and stuff like
that downtown so all these guys are
going missing now they really have no
idea what's going on at this stage there
are no bodies there are no nothing that
but they start to suspect this
particular investigator search he's like
this has got to be a serial killer
because most of the men that are missing
he's he's like they're about the same
type they're about the same height about
the same weight same hair claw same
appearance type thing and they hang out
at the same bar so he's like I feel like
someone is targeting them specifically
yeah this can't be a big gay community I
mean we're not talking about Fire Island
or anything like that yeah I mean it's a
big city but you know and so you kind of
get they said that you know a lot of gay
men would come there like from
especially if they were born and like
rural communities and stuff and they're
converging there yeah so so there was
actually they said at the time there
were 12 gay nightclubs in Indianapolis
and three gay papers like a specific
newspaper had bigger scene than I
thought yes a state yes I think yeah
they were to spend the weekend and that
kind of stuff right now really the only
clue they have at this point is that one
of the men who was missing and this was
one of the guys whose mothers had come
and reported him someone had seen him
getting into a car that had Ohio plates
on it and that's about all they know and
at this point the private investigator
is working with the editor of some of
the gay
magazines that gave newspapers in the
city tried to coordinate and trying to
you know putting up flyers and all the
clubs and trying to figure out what's
going on then two things kind of
happened simultaneously now they're
they're kind of thinking there was
actually one detective I think her name
is Mary Wilson and she was got
interested in the case so she kind of
wanted to look into it and so she's
working with vandagriff and while
they're investigating they find out that
there's another case that's going on in
Ohio now in Ohio in starting in 1989
there had been a bunch of bodies of men
found on the road between Indianapolis
like the interstate between Indianapolis
and Columbus Ohio and they called these
the i-70 murders and they figured that
this was probably a serial killer - and
they said now interestingly a lot of
those victims were also associated were
from Indianapolis and were associated
with the gay community Indianapolis so
there was like so maybe there's a
connection here now at this point a man
comes forward and he says I have a very
interesting story for you I was at this
bar and he's like and I saw this guy in
this club and he was looking at one of
the missing posters and seemed there
like there was just something really
weird about him and he's like and I kind
of got the idea that he maybe knew
something about it so he kind of wants
to see what's going on with this guy so
he goes home with the guy the guy said
his name was Brian smart and he said
that he was a landscaper and he's like
I'm gonna take you to the house where
I'm working right now he didn't say was
his house he said it was employers house
and he was staying there because he was
doing a job he said there's an indoor
pool and there's a bar by it it's really
not you know we'll party and stuff like
that the guy's like okay yeah so he goes
to the guys house now he doesn't know he
tells the police he's like I'm not sure
where the house is he's like it was
about a 20 mile drive it was north I
know that he's like but it was dark out
I'm not real familiar with that area but
he said it was a real rich area lots of
horse farms he said the house was a
Tudor mansion he said it had a really
really long curving driveway and he's
like and there was a like a split rail
fence in the front and it was a sign
that said farm something or something
farm but he couldn't remember the name
hadn't really seen it so he says they
get to the house he's like they go into
the pool area he's like it was really
weird because there was all these
mannequins like in all these different
outfits like all around the pool yeah
and he thought that was pretty weird and
he's like there was even one at the bar
like they were all dressed in different
costumes and stuff and he said you know
what's with all the mannequins and
quote-unquote Brian smart says oh the
owner has them here because he's
lonelier he likes to feel like there's
people here
he's like okay that's weird [ __ ] so then
this person says oh well do you want to
drink and this guy wisely says no thank
you
right yeah and then he's like oh well
I'm kind of into auto-erotic
asphyxiation do you know what that is
and stuff and and then he and then herb
Baumeister is who this guy is even
though he said he was Brian smart he
asks this guy who's usually he's usually
given a pseudonym Tony Harris usually
but on one of the documentaries they
identified him as Mark Goodyear I don't
know if that's actually his real name
because they only showed him in shadow
so herb asks mark will you strangle me
and so he's like okay so he does it and
then the herb kind of passes out and
he's like wow it's this big rush and
everything like that he's like can I do
it to you now and he's like okay really
so then he does it and then this guy
realizes he's not gonna stop he's just
gonna kill me so thinking very quickly I
have to say because I admired how his
quick thinking here he pretends to pass
out right and then herb lets go of him
and then he wakes back up and herbes
like oh yeah my bad sorry all this other
kind of [ __ ] right yeah so then Mark
gets the [ __ ] out of there yeah now he
reports to do with his hands or was he
doing it some of them showed with the
hands and some of it showed was like a
pool hose yeah garden hose yeah I
thought her like a garden hose I've seen
two versions right so I'm not real sure
okay so he reports this to the police
and he says I you know I feel really bad
I can't remember exactly where the house
is but he described it as well as he
could
vandagriff and the detective they kind
of drive out around that area looking
for it but they can't find anything so
there the case stagnates for about a
year and then they get a lucky break
because it seems that mark Goodyear
slashed Tony Harris would
whatever his real name is he's at a bar
one night in Indianapolis and he sees
this guy again
like he hasn't seen him for like a year
I guess you've been keeping a low
profile so he's like well okay well I
don't want him to see me right so he
kind of hides and he tells his friend
hey go follow that guy and get his
license-plate number yeah so the guy
does that to get his plate number they
report the plate number to the police
and the car is registered to herb
Baumeister Oh her all her now at this
stage the police do not know that
there's been a skull found in the
backyard of this house all they know is
that this guy has been seen at these
particular bars and that he might be
associated with some of the missing
people so the detective on the case Mary
Wilson she decides okay well I'm just
gonna straight up go to his place of
business and confine him about it so she
goes to save a lot and she says so what
do you know about all these people
missing from gay bars done in
Indianapolis
she called him very strange yeah and she
said immediately when we started talking
to him he got very very very nervous
yeah now they asked if they could search
his property he said no all right so
they said well maybe we can ask his wife
so they go to you know they go back to
the store when just she's there and
they're like look your husband is a
suspect in a case of homosexual homicide
which is what they call it I'm like how
is that different from regular homicide
homicide whatever right so and she's
like on there going well what does that
mean okay
figure it out like I said she seems like
kind of dim bulb so they was just
shocked her she couldn't process it
maybe yeah but yeah basically they're
telling you not only as your husband gay
and he's been cruising him gay bars but
we think that he might have been killing
them all and she's just like I don't
believe you and all this other stuff
they said well can we search the
property and she said no and still does
not tell them about the skull yeah ain't
that some [ __ ] that's what made me mad
about [ __ ] that's what makes me mad
about it I don't think she knew what he
was doing because when they checked her
calendar and when they checked the dates
that all the men went missing she should
have put she was always out of town like
she was always up at their lake house
she wasn't there it seemed like whenever
she would go out of town with the kids
he'd be like woohoo I can go yes
somebody yeah and let the house go to
[ __ ] and let the house go to [ __ ] yeah
because that was another thing that the
guy said he said the house was really
gross and dirty like they like there had
been no housekeeping done so I'm
assuming that the that her and the kids
would be off at the lake house and he
would just be there for however long and
he would just be a total slob yeah and
he would bring people home and stop and
kill him so after this started to happen
like the the cops were like well they
won't let us on the property we don't
have enough evidence to get a search
warrant so then they tried to search the
property by air like they got in a
helicopter and they used like an
infrared camera they said well maybe if
there are rotting bodies you know we can
see the heat signatures and stuff but
they didn't really see anything so like
okay well we have to get a search
warrant we have to get something in the
meantime
pretty much herb and Giuliana's life
starts going to [ __ ] he had actually
opened a second sav-a-lot thrift store
and pretty much immediately after that
happened the business started failing
they were facing bankruptcy and finally
he was just acting really strange and
having a meltdown and you know she you
know now that she knows that he's been
out cruising bars she files for divorce
so at this stage now the only person who
knew about the skull was Giuliana's
lawyer and because of you know
lawyer-client privilege or whatever like
he couldn't tell the police but finally
after the divorce and everything like
that and she starts to think you know
maybe there is something to this because
he's kind of acting crazy and stuff so
she calls her lawyer and says okay you
can tell police about the skull right so
they do tell police about the skull
which means that now the police can get
a search warrant right though I don't
really think they ended up needing one
because I think that herb went out to
the lake house and Giuliana told the
police you can come search the property
okay police come and search the property
and find over 5,000 bones in pretty much
two areas there's like an area that's
kind of off to one side of the house and
part of part of the bones like some of
the bones they found were like actually
kind of on the neighbor's property -
yeah putting it on the neighbors yeah I
guess so and they said most of those
bones
in tact there was also directly behind
the house was another area and most of
those bones were partially burned and
like crushed up right now they still
have no idea how many bodies this is
yeah it's at least eleven right but
probably more than that yeah one
surviving victim says that he confessed
to him that he'd killed over 50 yeah
between 50 and 60 people that's what
that guy said that it talked to him why
I think he said that herb would say that
he didn't really call it murderers he
would call it like accidents or mishaps
yes like he was just having auto-erotic
asphyxiation an oopsie went a little far
there 50 or 60 times yeah whatever okay
right so yeah so that guy did a joke on
a plow yeah it so it could be as many I
think his Wikipedia page says 11 to 20
some other sources I say could be 27
could be 29 the sad thing about it
though is that despite all these bone
fragments that they found and like we
said on the first part of the show they
still find them right only four people
have been positively identified they
know who they probably are because they
know who all the missing guys are from
that area from around that time but only
four of them have been positively
identified they found their teeth do
they really know what it was he was
doing with these guys was he just
strangling them out and then that was it
or was he strangled them out and then
having sex with the dead bodies or what
I don't know no because the thing is cuz
you actually brought that up because you
brought up the thing about the
mannequins because that's a very Jeffrey
Dahmer yeah John we wanted to make
basically sex dolls living sex doll
right tried to lobotomize kids and pour
Drano down in the brains you know I mean
all in the brain and pour Drano in it to
try to make a zombie basically and you
know somebody that would just be real
passive and not doing anything you know
which boy I would go to [ __ ] quick
wouldn't it well yeah how do you feed it
and then right and all of a sudden you
can't care for it so what do starves to
death you know just that's just a dumb
idea yeah what didn't maybe they didn't
they don't plan to keep him very long
but then you got this guy here and he's
choking him out to the wrong
conscious so what so he can treat him
like a doll see that this is what and
like I said this didn't even occur to me
and I am even like read any of this
until you said because yeah you because
you found it weird that he had the
mannequins like you yes sexual thing and
also yes he was having sex with he's met
a lot of times willingly and yeah he was
doing the autoerotic asphyxiation thing
but like you said did he do some with
their bodies after they were dead but
they wouldn't really know because all of
the bodies were they were all skeletons
and all of the skeleton most of the
skeletons were crushed up I think he was
doing mannequin like games with him yeah
it could be what I think was going on
it could be so yet I didn't even think
of that but he might have been massive
like that to get off the mat and the
mannequins were like substitutes for the
victims although what they're pitchers
they picture mostly female mannequins
but you know I don't know if that's true
there were well no because the pictures
from it which looked about half and half
and it looked like some female ones and
some melons I think it was a mannequin
fetish partner that just laid there or
you could just you know pose them yeah
something like that
oh yeah he's a weird dude I mean yeah
it's not talking about a normal guy at
all yeah that's what I mean and to me it
seems like it almost seems like if he
killed as many people as they think I
mean if it really was fifty people which
actually wouldn't shock me right then he
I feel like just strangling them and
throwing them in the backyard
I feel like he would have wanted to do
more with them than that because he was
weird here dude yeah they said he came
off as very off-putting yeah and yes so
they've only identified four of the
victims Roger Allen goodlet Steven Hale
Richard Hamilton and Manuel Resendez so
those are the only ones the if the other
ones are unidentified rest in peace
gentlemen Yeah right yeah now the creepy
thing is that as they were searching the
property yeah herb had taken one of
their sons Erik up to the lake house for
a vacation unexpectedly now when they
were searching the property they were
finding all these bones juliana started
flipping out she's like he's got our son
up there oh and by the way i feel bad
for these kids for his kids oh we have
to be tied in with a weirdo like that
yeah you know it's it's not on them it's
not their fault and that you know
they're never gonna live that down and
like I said I'm their mom I've you know
I don't think they haven't seen
interviews with the kids but they
interviewed the mom and several times
she's like these kids loved their dad he
was a good dad and you know well the
only saw one side of it they only saw
once yeah he had a total double life and
they had no idea so he had the son up at
the thing so Juliana and the cops and
her lawyer are like okay well we are
going to go up there and get the son
before this [ __ ] hits the news right
because we don't know how he's gonna
react right you know to us finding all
these bones the thing is the cops go up
to the lake which I think was about a
hundred miles from Fox Hollow Farm and
they get they get the boy with no
problem yeah and I'm guessing herb
didn't think anything about a murder
investigation or anything he just
thought oh well Giuliana's divorcing me
and this is like a legal maneuver or
whatever so he didn't seem to think he
wasn't suspected but the stupid thing is
that while they were up at the lake
getting the kid they didn't arrest herb
or they didn't have him watched or
anything
yeah this is some weird thing too this
whole case is like the local authorities
did not want to arrest him well the mom
how much stuff they had on the guy they
didn't want to arrest him
it makes me think he had gay dirt on
somebody he I he had to have some
blackmail [ __ ] on somebody because check
it out well the shitty thing that
happened was that the detective that was
working on a case Mary Mary Wilson she
was Indianapolis now since the crime are
the bodies the people went missing from
Indianapolis that was her beat but since
the bodies were found in Hamilton County
which was 20 miles away that was a
different jurisdiction yeah and so she
couldn't really tell them what to do
and it seemed like even though they
found all these bone fragments on the
property it's like they wouldn't arrest
they wouldn't even have him like they
wouldn't even put him under surveillance
nuts and so they go up to the lake they
get the kid and then they leave they
leave him there by himself here's
another thing we have a grown-ass man
who's supposed to have normal
intelligence just leaving these bodies
and these bones around evidently on the
surface on the surface of the earth to
the surface to the surface because they
were just people were just dumped I'm
not real worried about it because for
real when they first went out there
after Giuliana finally told about the
skull
everything you know the cops were like
well you know show us where the skull
was found so she goes out to the woods
to show them and they go out there and
he's like oh there's more yeah bones
ever there's teeth yes but they're just
laying there yeah they were just all
over the place they said it was just
like they said it's just like a cemetery
out there that's all over the place
actually less them worse than a cemetery
cemetery they're all contained in boxes
yes we're just out of scattered all over
the place they must have been burying
them in real shallow you know some
people say well maybe maybe animals got
it when animals didn't my experience of
when animals find another dead animal
they run off with it yeah I scattered
around everywhere yeah like one time you
know I threw out a dead turkey from a
chicken coop one time and I said I gave
later you know threw him out of the back
of a farm and went back I forgot to get
him went back about 6 hours later and he
was gone just gone and I'm you know and
I've been all over that property after
that it never saw a trace of that turkey
yeah not even a feather so you know the
animals take them I think if it was all
do to animals digging them up those
bodies would have been found by other
people because they ended up in on other
people's property I think I think he
kind of just left him on a surface maybe
I don't mean did I mean he couldn't have
left him on the surface on the surface
because his kids played out there what
maybe he burned him first I think yeah
through the bones upon the surface or he
had him decomposing in a certain spot
and then once they were all rotten
taking the bones and just throwing them
out I feel like a lot of them were
crushed up because like a lot of the
pieces that they found were very small
you know they did find bigger portions
later on like makes me think he had some
kind of compost pile going on somewhere
yeah he probably did and it must have
been in a secure location yeah maybe
somewhere in that house maybe there was
something like a little concrete chamber
where you don't know maybe work water
pipes could be and you could stash some
bodies there for the few months that you
need to get him to decompose out and you
know the smell is goat escapes out from
you know somewhere else something that
he found in the house where he could
stash a body let it rot yeah that's what
I think happened and then he's taking
the boat and he's cleaning it out taking
the bones out of there and just taught
him in the woods maybe that's just my
hypothesis I hadn't been to the area
yeah but I just find it strange that if
they were that close to
surface that the animals didn't get him
and scat him around everywhere that's
what I would think and and really if you
look as I saw like a um like a drone
picture of like the the property from
the air and it didn't really look like
the bones were not far from the house ya
know I mean the kids and [ __ ] like this
yeah it's like walking distance because
I mean evidently if he killed them in
the pool he would just drag him out of
the sliding glass door that's there in
the pool area and would presumably just
take them and throw him out in the back
but I don't know if that's what he did
or not or if like you said he had some
place that he stashed him in the house
there had to been some kind of service
crawlspace somewhere because whenever he
did it you know whatever he killed
somebody like I said Julianne the kids
were never there cuz ever because every
single time in her diary that she was
that her and the kids were on vacation
up at the lake house that was when the
men would go missing so he would wait
til they were gone and sometimes they
were gone for a while I would presume
for several days or maybe weeks or
whatever so he could he could have been
doing god-knows-what they don't know
what their did what he was doing in
there I got a weird feeling that there
was some kind of little service
crawlspace somewhere maybe not in the
house but you know on that compound
place where he could let him decompose
for a little while until they didn't
weigh very much he just took the bones
just throw him out in the yard
yeah cleared that space out again for
the next victims you might have two or
three of them in there rotting at the
same time yeah and some place where you
can keep him from four or five months or
something you know yeah something like
that but so okay so anyway the dumbass
cops you know they pick up the kid the
kid is fine you know he gives him up
with no problem but then they leave herb
at the lake house by himself now when
they go back up there later on like when
they finally are like oh maybe we should
arrest this guy since there's [ __ ]
five thousand bones in his yard
right yeah they go back to the lake
house and of course he's gone yeah now
they don't know where he is for eight
days yeah nobody knows where he is yeah
and then finally on July 3rd 1996 they
find his dead body in Canada in a park
some sources say he's in the car some
sources say he's next to the car he shot
himself in the head yeah he left a
3-page suicide note
by all accounts very rambling he
apologized for his
failing marriages failing business
setting about how much he loved his
children ended it with a very weird
phrase he said I'm going to eat a peanut
butter sandwich and go to sleep okay
he mentions nothing about the murders
nothing about the bones nothing yeah
yeah what an [ __ ] yeah didn't confess
didn't confess nothing well boys is that
you did not mention this probably cuz it
wasn't a big deal to him you know maybe
not yeah not a big deal them people
didn't matter to him yeah yeah the weird
thing about it is that like I said now
some sources say I did it doesn't matter
if he was found in the car outside of
the car said he shot himself at the
forehead which is kind of hard to do but
hold it like that yeah I guess yeah but
the weird thing about it is that on the
stupid Ghost Adventures show that they
did about this yeah [ __ ] Zack goes
and talks to Virgil vandagriff you know
the private investigator who worked on
the case now vandagriff says that when
they found her Baumeister's body in the
park that herb looked like he had posed
himself ritualistically hmm before he
killed himself like on the reenactment
they showed him lying on the ground like
almost in a Christ kind of pose with
like a dead birds around him yeah but I
have seen no other source that said that
because I I don't know if the Ghost
Adventures people told Virgil to say
that so then Zack could go oh well maybe
you know herb did some ritual so his
spirit would haunt the earth or whatever
you know cuz that's exactly of course
what Zack said afterward but I have
never seen any other thing refer to his
death being unusual in any way it just
looked like a straight-up sue is he just
shot himself in the head in his car or
outside of his car yes so I don't know
if they told Virgil to say that because
I didn't see that detail anywhere else
except on that chef sex game man so he
shot himself and you know good riddance
yeah but it's kind of sucks for the
victims families because they have no
idea they have no idea what happened to
their sons their brothers you know they
they will never know because the dudes
dead and the shitty thing too is that
later on when they were trying to tie
together because remember I mentioned
the i-70 murders like all the bodies
that have found alongside the interstate
turned out that herb probably did those
two
cuz Juliana was like yeah he used to go
to Columbus Ohio on business all the
time and he used to drive that road all
the time and the interesting thing was
that those birders stopped as soon as he
bought Fox Hollow Farm yeah cuz now he
had room right by his house to throw the
bodies instead of having to dump them
off on the side of the interstate [ __ ]
her [ __ ] her [ __ ] her so like I said
Wikipedia is like they know he killed at
least 11 okay that they found at least
11 distinct bodies on his property but
it could be as many as 60 yeah
I've seen between 11 and 20 I've seen em
say 27 so I'm say 29 I don't think they
will ever know only four of them have
been identified and like I said I'm sure
that his wife did not know and I feel
bad for her yeah but in a way they
interviewed some of the victims families
on this particular documentary I saw the
woman Bill Curtis one the one of the
victims sisters I believe she was like
that [ __ ] should have known I mean she
said that but she's like she must have
known about it so I can see how she
maybe didn't know because they were
apart a lot I think she was in denial
she says yeah yeah maybe she suspected I
don't know
now one thing that I can get mad at her
about is not telling the cops about that
skull because if she had told now two
men disappeared yeah after she found
that skull right and if she had found
that then those people might still be
alive
yeah and they had one of the one of the
victims mothers on there and you know
once the skull was found and Giuliana
told herb hey where'd the skull from
from psycho it's just my dad's skull and
then the skull disappeared so nobody
knows where it was like what he did with
it he crushed that up and got rid of it
right and so like one of the victims
mothers was like you know if she had
told if she had turned that skull inch
like that could have been my son and now
I will never know yeah and that is just
really really upsetting so I can get up
her ass about that it's like I'm not
gonna blame her for his [ __ ] and I'm
sure she didn't know but really you find
a skull in your backyard please report
that [ __ ] it's like you know what I mean
it's like she could have saved those two
people maybe that would have happened
anyway maybe they would have died anyway
but you know maybe
maybe those people wouldn't be dead if
she had reported it so I'm just saying
so yeah that's the Fox Hollow Farm case
went a little bit long but you know it's
not so good it's kind of a lot of detail
to go into so I hope you guys kind of
enjoyed this super-sized paranormal
/yeah episode yeah there's a lot of
stuff about on this one you know oh yeah
guys doing guys doing their own little
ghost investigations so you'll have you
can have hours of enjoyment and like I
said there's at least two or three no
actually more like four or five
different crime documentaries like they
were on discovery or investigations
there's a good chance there's a good
chance this could be a haunted house I
would live the [ __ ] out of that haunted
house though I would live in a beautiful
house yeah it's really beautiful I mean
you can see it Ghost Adventures
on their website they actually took a
bunch of pictures of the interior next
year it's gorgeous yeah
all right so that'll do it for episode
82 remember to if you like the show to
like share support on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show that would be very nice
you can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock or you can
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's a link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account if
you'd like to have a one-time donation
also check out our Zazzle store
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock we have
t-shirts and tote bag and a tote bag
there for your enjoyment also check out
our latest movie review which was the
changeling and we will have more to come
on this upcoming Friday also remember to
check out my book that faceless villain
if you haven't already volume one is out
and I'm still working on volume two
should be out sometime before summer or
early summer so keep an eye out for that
and until next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you